eine stunde noch bis zum anpfiff
deutschland gegen ungarn
umso mehr freuen wir uns dass ihr hier
bei uns dabei seid denn wir wollen in
den nächsten 30 minuten reden und wir
versprechen auch dass wir pünktlich
fertig werden willkommen zur heute live
ja die allianz arena darf heute abend
nicht in regenbogenfarben erstrahlen es
gibt eine riesenaufregung darüber und
wir wollen reden ist die aufregung
berechtigt oder nicht
ich freue mich auf eine spannende
diskussion weil ich denke dass wir
durchaus unterschiedliche meinungen
hören werden wir werden zum einen marco
scholten zu gast haben
er ist fußballer im ersten schwulen
fußball team das im ligabetrieb des dfb
spielt und wir werden gerhard papke zu
gast haben er wird auch da sein und er
spricht als vorsitzender der deutsch
ungarischen gesellschaft schreibt eure
fragen eure kommentare
in der an die adresse die ihr hier und
nur eingeblendet seht oder schreibt sie
einfach in die kommentarspalten
wir werden gleich auch mit unserem
korrespondenten und mit unserem
korrespondenten in budapest und münchen
sprechen aber vorher was die uefa
bestimmt nicht wollte ist die gewaltige
protestwelle die sie ausgelöst hat und
da hat uns jan frederik fischer die
reaktionen im netz zusammen gesucht
rot orange gelb grün blau violett der
protest gegen die uefa
er ist bunt und vielfältig da sind
promis mit ihren bildern und videos ein
zeichen setzen wollen
comicfiguren die stellung beziehen
fußballvereine die ihre bunten stadien
zeigen und maskottchen die sich gleich
mit positionieren auf vielen profilen
scheint die regenbogenfahne heute
schlichtweg zu dominieren
ebenso in einer kleinen parallelwelt
auch die faz am mittag mit und postet
ein tweet sand und im logo
[Musik]
leicht mit dir hallo stefan
die an den ort des geschehens aber bevor
dann schauen wir mal
detroit
wir sind wer
ganz deutschland haben städte vereine
gebäude angekündigt ihre gebäude heute
haben zum spiel zu beleuchten und einige
schöne form abgefangen letztmals zum
beispiel hier gestern abend in hamburg
das ist die elbphilharmonie in
regenbogenfarben und auch diese
hamburger bahn station war bunt
beleuchtet heute mittag hat schon das
weserstadion in bremen nachgezogen
allerdings nicht mit beleuchtung sondern
mit flaggen rund um das stadion und
solche flaggen wandern auch im rest von
bremen zu sehen überall in der stadt
verteilt zum beispiel vor geschäften und
restaurants und auch münchen hat die
flaggen gehisst das rathaus auf dem
marienplatz heute mit bunten regenbogen
farben im versteck münchen brachte es
trotzdem
kurz
ja das ist die spannende frage hier
viele schauen sich im sekundentakt um
und schauen auf diese luftkissen hülle
des stadions hier im moment ist genau
der moment abgepasst wir sind also
gerade richtig hier in münchen wo das
licht angeschaltet wird bisher war es
weiß und neutral
aber jetzt im moment sind es die farben
der uefa also der organisatoren dieses
turniers die hier leuchten aber wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass sich die
stadt münchen und die betreiber dieses
stadions an das verbot der uefa erhalten
werden und nachher während des spiels
dieses stadion nicht in regenbogenfarben
sondern eben in schwarz-rot-gold und in
den farben ungarns erleuchten
ich habe ein bisschen den stimmungs
vergleich denn ich war auch beim spiel
deutschland gegen frankreich hier und
das was wir im moment erleben
das übertrifft noch das was beim ersten
spiel der deutschen hier an stimmung los
war das hat natürlich mit der aufgeladen
hyde der debatte und dieses spiel zu tun
und wenn ich mich umschaue dann sehe ich
lauter regenbogen flaggen lauter
regenbogen utensilien es gibt masken die
hier in großer stückzahl verteilt werden
in den farben des regenbogens also die
stimmung ist gut hier und es ist vor
allem die farbe des regenbogens die hell
leuchtet auch wenn es nicht das stadion
ist die frage gewesen ob diese
regenbogen diskussionen
spielwaren ein großes thema ist oder
auch die meisten fans sagen gewonnen
nein es ist der erste das die meisten
fans gehen mit dem bewusstsein dieser
diskussion hier ins stadion
man kann daran auch gar nicht vorbei
weil es so omnipräsent ist und bei mir
steht jetzt ein gast der nachher auch
beim spiel zu gast sein wird im stadion
alex kluge er ist der organisator des
christopher street day here in münchen
also der gay pride die normalerweise
wenn ich gerade corona ist in münchen in
der stadt stattfindet herr kluge das was
wir heute erleben ist doch für sie ein
guter ersatz
also als würde ich das nicht nennen bei
der kristallhütte findet statt wenn auch
in anderer form aber das ist ein
wirklich ganz außergewöhnliches tolles
ereignis mit dem wir die ursprünglich
gar nicht gerechnet hatten
hat ihnen die uefa am ende trotz des
verbots vielleicht sogar noch geholfen
das kann man mit einem ganz klaren ja
beantworten die solidarität die uns
jetzt in den letzten tagen im vorfeld
erreicht hat die es gewaltig also hier
in der landeshauptstadt münchen von der
kindertagesstätte bis zu den großen
unternehmen alle haben sich bei uns
gemeldet und gesagt wir sind dabei wir
leuchten uns war unternehmen usw
was für gefühlen gehen sie jetzt hier im
stadion zum spiel gespannt ich bin sehr
gespannt was im stadion passiert
spannend es auch weil es mein erster
stadionbesuch überhaupt das aber der
mehrzahl mal wegen der regen beruf lang
vielen dank also ein spiel das sowohl
eine sportliche als auch eine politische
dimension hat hier in münchen
er sagt nämlich genau dasselbe johannes
selbe wie der film den wir ihnen hören
durften
er sagt mal im ernst ohne dass
vom verbot hätte dieses thema in dieser
woche minimal sind viel aufmerksamkeit
generieren lernwillig
das kann jeder für sich
es ist tatsächlich so dass ich da ganz
ja ich glaube das kann man eindeutig mit
ja beantworten am anfang herrschte
natürlich die enttäuschung vor darüber
dass die uefa nein gesagt hat zum antrag
der stadt münchen aber das was dann am
ende an regenbogenfarben novelle um die
welt gegangen ist das war wahrscheinlich
um ein vielfaches größer als das was an
wirkung entfaltet worden wäre wenn diese
stadion einfach den regenbogen flaggen
oder farben angeknipst worden wäre also
das nein der uefa hat am ende dieser
diskussion eher in diese richtung
befördert
stefan torwart manuel neuer wird ja
voraussichtlich wieder seine
kapitänsbinde tragen in den
regenbogenfarben und das toleriert warum
dann nicht auch im rund des stadions
lage unterrichten
da gibt es zwei antworten darauf die
einen sagen das ist das zeigt die ganze
bigotterie der uefa dass eine binde zwar
okay sein soll aber ein beleuchtetes
stadion nicht die anderen sagen na ja da
gibt es schon unterschiede denn diese
binde die manuel neuer getragen hat bei
den letzten spielen die geht ja von ihm
selber aus und hier wäre es die uefa
quasi selbst die das licht anknipsen
müsste das ist natürlich eine sehr
feinsinnige unterscheidung die man davon
leben müsse aber insgesamt hat sich die
uefa mit dieser diskussion und ihre
entscheidung sowieso keinen gefallen
getan sie hat sich ein doppeltes
eigentor geschossen zum einen weil sie
jetzt ziemlich einsam an der seite von
viktor orban steht und eine welle des
protests entgegen nehmen muss und zum
anderen weil sie eigentlich ihr eigenes
argument widerlegt hat und dieses
argument lautete ja immer fußball ist
unpolitisch und das was man heute sieht
das zeigt eindrucksvoll dass das fußball
ganz und gar nicht unpolitisch ist die
entscheidung beschämend wie du sagst hat
sich die
so etwa da vielleicht ein eigentor
geschossen um im fußball bleiben oder
aber vielleicht dieser antrag
da gibt es manche die das am anfang
kritisiert haben denn der op der
oberbürgermeister münchens dieter reiter
hat sehr politisch und sehr konkret
argumentiert und hat gesagt diese
regenbogenfarbene beleuchtung am stadion
und die soll ganz gezielt an ungarn an
viktor orban an dieses gesetz was ungarn
verabschiedet hat das ungarische
parlament gerichtet sein
und das hat es für die uefa dann relativ
leicht gemacht zu sagen das ist so
politisch und so konkret gegen eine
regierung gerichtet so eine botschaft
passt nicht zu unserem auftrag als
europäischer fußball verband deswegen
gab es viele die gesagt haben er hätte
das noch viel allgemeiner folien
formulieren können und einfach sagen
können man wolle generell ein zeichen
für transparenz setzen
so ist es jetzt nicht gekommen am ende
muss man aber sagen hat sich die stadt
münchen hiermit schon auch einen
gefallen getan weil diese diskussion ist
um die welt gegangen und münchen hat
damit ein großes zeichen gesetzt wir
haben viele fahnen gesehen partner die
im hintergrund
und wenn sie einen fußballer
da kommt die flagge chinas werden
danke stefan christ und jetzt sprechen
wir mit unseren content in britta
hilpert
da geht es ein bisschen ruhiger zu
britta in budapest bei dir diese ganze
diskussion die regenbogenfahnen wie
wetters denn bei dir auf der straße
wahrgenommen wie es in budapest die
stimme also erstmal muss sondern sollen
dass ich hier heute in budapest eine
einzige regenbogen fahne gesehen habe
wieder hier in dieser fan zone noch
sonst irgendwo in budapest wird diese
debatte wahrgenommen vor allen dingen
als ein angriff auf ungarn also von
vielen wird das so wahrgenommen
natürlich nicht von allen wenn wir hier
mit den leuten sprechen mit den
fußballfans an heißt es vor allen dingen
erst einmal politik ist das eine
und fußball ist das andere das ist die
meinung die wir ganz häufig hören von
vielen ungarn
es ist aber schon natürlich auch so dass
gerade hier in budapest in der
hauptstadt es große demonstrationen
gegeben hat gegen das gesetz das es hier
eine mehrheit von menschen gibt laut
einer umfrage die ein problem mit diesem
gesetz haben aber das eben zwei
millionen hauptstädter 9 millionen
ungarn insgesamt gegenüber stehen und in
der provinz sieht das bild hat ein
bisschen anders aus die regenbogenfahne
steht ich lese es mal vor als symbol für
die akzeptanz und gleichberechtigung von
menschen die sich nicht mit dem
traditionellen rollenbild von mann und
frau oder anderen normen rund um
gleichberechtigung und sexualität
identifizieren welches problem hat die
ungarische regierung damit
die ungarische regierung sieht das als
widerspruch zu ihrem streben nach wie
soll ich sagen ungarischer identität zu
ungarischen nachwuchs sozusagen
sie hatte im letzten jahr schon in der
verfassung verankern lassen dass die
familie immer aus mutter vater und
kindern besteht das heißt dass de facto
zum beispiel adoptionen von
gleichgeschlechtlichen partnern
adoptionen von kindern nicht mehr
möglich ist
hochzeiten heiraten von
gleichgeschlechtlichen partnern sind
nicht mehr möglich also da wurden auch
im gesetzestext fakten geschaffen die
eben gegen dieser idee einer regenbogen
gesellschaft entgegen stehen wenn wir
dabei sind vielleicht kannst du noch mal
kurz den stein des anstoßes erklären was
hat es denn mit diesem gesetz auf sich
dass die ungarische regierung jetzt
beschlossen wird es gegen pädophilie
fanden wir sind hier natürlich auch im
vorlauf zu dem spannenden spiel deswegen
passiert da hinter mir natürlich auch
das eine oder andere die ungarische
regierung sagt dieses gesetz sei eines
das die kinder vor pädophilen schützen
soll und das ist eben auch genau das
problem dass die eu kommission sieht sie
sieht dass pädophilie und homosexualität
in diesem gesetz gleich behandelt werden
nun ist es aber natürlich was anderes ob
jemand sex mit kindern hat oder
erwachsene männer konsensual sex
miteinander haben und aus diesem grund
hat die kommission ein problem damit und
hat das heute in starken bord nach
dargelegt aber die ungarische regierung
sagt dieses gesetz diskriminiere nicht
gegen homosexuelle über 18 und deswegen
beruhe die behauptung der europäischen
kommission auf einer unwahrheit und das
sei eine schande
sie nutzt also dieses wort schon die
ihrerseits wiederum um anwürfe gegen die
europäische kommission loszuwerden
du hast die eu gerade angesprochen alle
green egg unsere korrespondenten aus
brüssel hat dazu einen beitrag gemacht
den wollen wir uns kurz anschlag die
elbphilharmonie leuchtet im regenbogen
outfit das fußballstadion im belgischen
gent das rathaus von münchen eine
regenbogenfarbene welle der entrüstung
über das ungarische homosexuellen gesetz
rollt durch europa und wird morgen sogar
den gipfel der eu staats und
regierungschefs erfassen
der öffentliche druck zwingt auch die eu
kommissionspräsident hin zum handeln
das ungarische gesetz ist eine schande
dieses gesetz diskriminiert menschen
eindeutig ihrer sexuellen orientierung
wegen nimmt ungarn das gesetz nicht
zurück droht die eu-kommission mit einer
klage vor dem europäischen gerichtshof
ein weiteres von über 100
vertragsverletzungsverfahren die viktor
orban bereits am hals hat der ungarische
premierminister schlägt am nachmittag
zurück nicht sein gesetz dass kinder
schütze sei eine schande sondern die
erklärung der eu kommissionspräsident in
die ungarischen fußball stadien sollen
am abend demonstrativ in den
nationalfarben erstrahlen
ja da ist der begriff schande dann noch
mal gefallen welchen eindruck macht das
alles auf ministerpräsident orban wird
es irgendetwas ändern
also ich glaube nicht dass er zurück
oder das auf gar keinen fall im
gegenteil heute nachmittag hat der
präsident der republik ungarn das gesetz
unterschrieben und es ist damit de facto
in kraft orban hat ja wie gesagt auch
gesagt er seiner seite seine schande wie
die eu kommission aneinander behandeln
und die ungarischen medien die ja hier
größtenteils sehr regierungsnahe
berichten wir richten eben auch dass
ungarn wieder mal unter beschuss sei der
europäischen union dass man wieder mal
ein angriff auf die ungarische identität
und nationalität es sei eine innere
angelegenheit in die sich die eu nicht
einzumischen habe
so wird das hier kolportiert dazu habe
ich einen kommentar auf youtube von sap
der sagt es geht nicht gegen den
regenbogen an sich es geht darum dass
man ungarn und orban in
anführungszeichen sagt er seine wortwahl
anpassen will
und damit ist es politisch wetters in
ungarn auch so wahrgenommen dass orban
angepisst wird von der europäischen
union was man so zu wenn du das so sagen
möchte ist genauso machen ja so ist das
gemeint also wenn die zuschauer das so
meint so gibt es tatsächlich hier sicher
die viele ungarn die das genauso sehen
das ist aber auch der spin den die
regierung selber raus gibt das muss man
ja auch sagen es ist eben tatsächlich so
dass die allermeisten und die
wichtigsten medien in diesem land
regierungsnah sind das haben wir ja in
den letzten jahren schon beobachtet und
so wird dann einseitig dargestellt warum
orban warum die regierung aber dieses
gesetz machen will und warum das aus
sicht von orban gute gründe sein dieses
gesetz zu machen
man muss eine sache verstehen verstehen
ihr wahlen an in ungarn im nächsten jahr
und viktor orban hat in den letzten
wahlkämpfen die erfahrung gemacht dass
er immer dann stärker wird wenn er von
außen angefeindet wird das heißt für ihn
kann es sein dass es auch kalkül ist den
konflikt mit der europäischen union
einzugehen
es macht ihnen nur stärker insbesondere
natürlich dann wenn die presse in seinem
sinn berichtet und das ist hier in
ungarn größtenteils der fall
es kann also sein dass es für ihn gar
nicht so schlecht ist dass er nun diesen
konflikt mit der europäischen union
langfristig so war es zumindest bisher
die erfahrung hat ihn das nur gestärkt
ritter letzte frage ministerpräsident
orban gilt ja eigentlich durchaus als
fußballfan und man wäre normalerweise
davon ausgegangen dass er sich heute
abend in münchen hätte gezeigt er ist
nicht da was denkst du wegen der
regenbogen farben also dass orban bei
einem spiel der ungarischen
nationalmannschaft nicht dabei ist ist
also das hat überhaupt noch nicht
gegeben
aber man hat selber mal gesagt er würde
immer immer immer zu einem spiel der
ungarischen nationalmannschaft fahren
egal wo auf der welt
und ausgerechnet heute abend hat er nun
terminprobleme das erscheint auch vielen
ungarn sehr unwahrscheinlich aber sie
unterstützen ihren ministerpräsidenten
also viele zumindest mit denen wir
gesprochen haben unterstützen ihren
ministerpräsidenten auch darin zu sagen
warum soll es sich dem aussetzen warum
soll er dann nach deutschland fahren und
viele zuschauer geben sagte sich
anpassen lassen
wenn sie doch meinen er habe recht mit
dem was er tue
das ist eben das problem in dieser
ungarischen gesellschaft dass die
vielfalt auch in der berichterstattung
fehlt und bei dieser vielfalt in der
berichterstattung fehlt ist es so dass
die mehrheitsmeinung hier in ungarn
natürlich auch eher auf der seite der
regierung
britta hilpert in budapest ich danke dir
ganz herzlich für deine politische
analyse und deine informationen und auch
hier in budapest noch einen film
fußballabend und jetzt möchte ich mit
marco scholtes und gerhard papke
sprechen
schönen guten abend schön dass sie dabei
sind er schaltet ich fange mal mit ihnen
an sie spielen ich habe vorhin schon
gesagt beim team street boys münchen
das ist die erste schwule fußball
mannschaft die im offiziellen liga
betrieb des dfb spielt männerfußball
homosexuellen homosexualität das ist ja
irgendwie nach wie vor ein thema möchten
sie uns mal aus ihrem fußball alltag
erzählen erst mal im wunderschönen guten
abend ja es ist ein thema im fußball im
fußball alltag
es wird leider immer noch zu einem thema
im fußball alltag gemacht sollte es
allerdings nicht sein
es geht los von anfeindungen der
gegenspielern wir haben dumme sprüche
die möchte ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht wirklich wahr geben was wir da
so an den kopf geschmissen bekommen
vor ein paar jahren waren es auch noch
tätlichkeiten uns gegenüber
das ging hin bis zu einer gebrochenen
nase unseres kapitäns
es mussten auch schon spiele abgebrochen
werden weil die gegner vom platz
gestellt wurden mit roth aufgrund der
tätlichkeiten also es geht bis ganz
runter geht es mit den homophoben
anfeindungen im deutschen fussball
leider was denken sie warum hat
männerfußball so ein problem mit der
homosexualität also wir denken wir an
thomas hitzlsberger dass es so weit ich
weiß glaube ich der einzige profi
fußballer gewesen der sich geoutet hat
aber dann auch erst nach seiner aktiven
karriere was wo ist das problem jetzt
hat ja zum beispiel gerade diese woche
karl jasik der football profi in den usa
sich geoutet und der hat wiederum sehr
sehr viel zuspruch bekommen
denken sie dass ich da gerade was ändert
das absolut richtig und also ich und
auch meine mannschaftskollegen und auch
alle die ich aus der aus der community
kennen wir ziehen uns
ruth vorvorgängers gibt das hat er ganz
großartig gemacht
thomas hitzlsperger hat es auch gemacht
nach seiner aktiven karriere ich gehe
davon aus dass der verein auch schon so
weit gewesen wäre ihn zu unterstützen
respektive auch der dfb wäre
wahrscheinlich schon weiter gewesen als
vielleicht vor 10 15 jahren
ich glaube allerdings oder wir glauben
dass das problem einfach abseits des
platzes ist dass das defense oftmals
damit nicht umgehen können oder auch
eben auch leider andere länder damit
involviert sind das bedeutet ich nehme
das mal als beispiel wenn ein fußballer
aus der bundesliga sich outet und dann
ins ausland wechseln möchte
der offen schwul lebt denke ich mal dass
er ein großes problem haben wird weil
viele länder einfach eben noch nicht so
weit oder so offen so tolerant sind wie
es deutschland schon ist und nehmen auch
als beispiel philipp lahm er rät jedem
fußballer ist nichts zu tun im wir sagen
natürlich tut es weil der erste der
anfängt löste eine kettenreaktion aus
und dann machen es auch andere kommen
wir vielleicht noch mal zu dieser
regenbogenfahnen diskussion zurück papke
ich habe sie schon angekündigt und
vorgestellt sie sind vorsitzender der
deutsch ungarischen gesellschaft wie
sehen sie die diskussionen der
vergangenen tage
die diskussionen hat es weitgehend
ausgeblendet wie sie in ungarn kommen
musste
die reden ja nicht über ein allgemeines
signal diversität und liberalität
sondern das hat der münchner
oberbürgermeister auch klar beschrieben
das ganze war geplant als eine
politische demonstration als eine
politische kampagne gegen ungarn
und man muss sich das mal vorstellen die
ungarische mannschaft kommt als gast zu
uns nach deutschland und muss erleben
dass ihr ganzes land vorgeführt werden
sollen auf die anklagebank gesetzt
werden soll von der gesamten
weltöffentlichkeit
die ungarn sind ein sehr stolzes volk
dass sie sich das nicht bieten lassen
wollen kann ich gut verstehen und ich
sage auch ganz ehrlich dass das neue
verständnis
die deutsche gastfreundschaft ist
anderen völkern gegenüber die bei
sportveranstaltungen zu uns kommen dann
müssen wir uns nicht wundern wenn wir
bald in der welt keine freunde wir haben
ganz abgesehen davon dass dann
internationale sportereignisse nicht
mehr möglich sein werden
wenn nämlich gastgeberländer bei solchen
fußballspielen oder anderen
sportereignissen dieser kategorie auf
die idee kommen eigene politische
statements damit verbinden zu wollen
dann sind wir wieder da wo wir mal in
den 80er jahren als im kalten krieg
abwechselnd olympische spiele portiert
wurden das würde den sport völlig
überfrachtet also es ist eine sehr kluge
entscheidung der uefa gewesen eine
politische kampagne gegen ungarn heute
haben nicht zuzulassen verpackter sie
sagen im prinzip ungarn wäre mit so
einer aktion entwürdigt worden
jetzt denken dass mal andersrum das wird
jetzt nicht gemacht dass das stadion
beleuchtet wird könnte es nicht
passieren dass sich jetzt homosexuelle
menschen entwürdigt fühlen dadurch dass
eben kein zeichen gesetzt wird was
denken sie
also ich bitte die wir haben eine ganz
andere debatte gehabt wenn man auf die
idee gekommen wäre
diese beleuchtung beispielsweise vor dem
frankreich spiel zu machen aber sie ist
begründet worden mit der politischen
aktion gegen ungarn und damit blieb der
racer gar nichts anderes übrig als
einzuschreiten weil wenn der sport mit
solchen politischen initiativen belastet
wird wie ich gerade erneut darüber dann
wird in zukunft nicht mehr möglich sein
und im übrigen was mich im letzten tag
auch sehr gestört hat ist die sachliche
vorwurf der homophobie das ist ein
totschlag und niemand sagt unterschreibt
das ist ein grund geheim das institut
eine eingetragene partnerschaft für
gleichgeschlechtliche
lebensgemeinschaften gegen homosexuelle
können in ungarn leben wie sie möchten
nach ihrer fasson und ich frage mich bei
solchen debatten immer wieder
deshalb meinen wir deutsche
anderen völkern immer erklären zu müssen
wie freiheitlichen demokratie und
rechtsstaat funktioniere die umwelt sind
ein fragendes soll das sehr lange für
seinen freund und seine demokratie haben
kämpfen müssen
die brauchen nicht ständig
nachhilfeunterricht und schon gar die
von uns deutschen die freiheitliche
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
funktioniert brauchen sie wirklich nicht
das konservative aber weil ich denke was
wir jetzt an dieser stelle brauchen ist
die perspektive von herrn scholtes die
würde mich jetzt mal interessieren was
sagen sie dazu
ja ich muss dazu ganz ehrlich sagen also
ich finde nicht dass das ungarn
entwürdigt wurde durch durch die debatte
um die um die regenbogen sondern ich
finde andersrum orban hat alle in der lg
cube plus community entwürdigt durch
sein verhalten durch ein durch verbote
in seinem eigenen land und dann auch
noch wie freund schon im beitrag auch
gesagt wurde er besucht jedes spiel der
nationalmannschaft und plötzlich nur
weil er meint man könnte ihm endlich mal
gegenwind entgegen bringen bleibt er weg
bleibt sofern finde ich einfach genau
das gegenteil von dem das deutschland
ungarn entschuldigt hat und ich finde
einfach wir sollten auch aufhören zu
sagen wir dürfen nicht anderen landen
ländern sagen die sie zu leben haben wir
wollen das gar nicht wir wollen bloß
dass alle menschen gleich behandelt
werden
und es ist einfach entwürdigend wenn
zwei männer sich lieben und dann keine
kinder adoptieren dürfen oder mit einem
lesbischen kirchen in derart
leihmutterschaft kinderkriegen
dazu war ist ein kommentar von ihr aus
von youtube von jana sie schreibt meiner
meinung nach sollte deutschland
rechtspopulismus und
menschenfeindlichkeit laut kritisieren
sonst haben wir aus unserer
vergangenheit leider nicht gelernt habe
packe wie sehen sie das
wenn ein kleines langsam in gang kommt
dass man
bei uns zu hause in deutschland
öffentlich vorführt stellen wir uns mal
fordert spielen würde heute nicht in
münchen sondern in budapest stattfinden
meinen sie wirklich der dfb hätte dann
den mut gehabt so großzügig regenbogen
fähnchen zu verteidigen
wir haben in anderthalb jahren die
fußball wm in katar
das ist ein land in dem homosexuelle ins
gefängnis geworfen werden
ganz brutal geächtet werden im land wo
ist da die diskussion bei uns auf
deutschland an einer solchen fußball
beendete einem solchen land wo
gleichgeschlechtliche
lebensgemeinschaften denkbar sind wo
schwule und lesben verfolgt werden
überhaupt teilnehmen sollte das wird
komplett ausgeblendet wenn es um
frauenrechte und die rechte von
homosexuellen in arabischen ländern gehe
ich dann aber packte wenn ich da mal
kurz ein haken darf diese diskussion
geht er durchaus dann herrscht in
deutschland dröhnendes schweigen in ein
kleines land in dem ganze gas ist in dem
homosexuelle dabei bleibe ich in frieden
leben können dann werden die regenbogen
flaggen geschwenkt und dann wird diesem
land vorgeworfen
das ist nicht her und das entspricht
auch nicht den tatsachen thema katar die
diskussionen laufen und die werden mit
sicherheit geht es auf die wm zu noch
mal ordentlich hoch kochen deshalb ist
es möglicherweise wir sprechen dann noch
mal zu sehen gibt es diese diskussion
also es hat sie in der vergangenheit
immer mal wieder gegeben und wenn solche
ereignisse dann anstehen dann kochen sie
ja auch immer wieder hoch was mich noch
mal interessieren würde herr schulte ist
was würden sie sagen solche solche
protest wählen wie wichtig sind die für
sie bringt das mehr akzeptanz auch wenn
es eine große diskussion gibt ja ja es
kommt immer auf die art der proteste an
ich bin eigentlich ein mensch der sich
hinstellt und sagt man sollte man sollte
nicht immer alles gleich politisch
machen man kann auch mal alle neune
gerade sein
aber gerade wenn es darum geht menschen
rechte einzuschränken
nehmen wir doch einfach mal jetzt die
krone station es hat immer geheißen
deutschland schränkt die grundrechte im
endeffekt haben wir das nicht gemacht
dann hat es geheißen
es werden menschenrechte eingeschränkt
und auch da gab es diskussionen aber
wenn wirklich menschenrechte
eingeschränkt werden wie jetzt aktuell
in ungarn durch dieses neue gesetz
verabschiedet wurde daran finde ich
sollten wir auf die straße gehen und wir
sollten noch viel mehr auf die straße
gehen aber ich muss auch ganz explizit
dazu sagen wir sollten gewaltfrei auf
die straße gehen wir können alles mit
worten reden wir können alles mit mit
mit mit fahnen regeln wir können alles
mit mit mit mit gesten regeln aber wir
müssen definitiv gewaltfrei auf die
straße gehen und das müssen wir tag für
tag machen zu dem thema katar dass herr
papke angesprochen hat gibt es
tatsächlich dann auch noch mal eine
frage vielleicht an sie auch handschuhe
schals oder verpackte wenn sie möchten
auf facebook fragt lucy was für ein
zeichen wird die mannschaft 1 x 1 x die
deutschen nationalmannschaft denn in
katar setzen wo es nicht nur um die lgbt
tv sondern auch um frauenrechte sehr
schlecht bestellt ist wird man da dann
auch regenbogen artig auftreten was
würden sie sich denn wünschen habt ihr
zum beispiel sie haben das thema ja
gerade angesprochen also ich glaube dass
man ernsthaft diskutieren müsste ob man
in einem solchen land überhaupt eine
fußballweltmeisterschaft veranstalten
ein land in dem frauen rechte und rechte
von homosexuellen derart ignoriert und
verletzt werden kann doch nicht
ernsthaft der austragungsort für eine
fußball weltmeisterschaft sein aber da
höre ich in deutschland und auch in der
fifa international überhaupt keine
ansätze um klipp und klar zu sagen
dort dürfen wir nicht spielen und das
ist genau diese ungleichbehandlung die
mich so unglaublich gestört hat in den
letzten tagen in ungarn haben wir einen
europäischen partner ein land in dem
deutschland sehr geschätzt wird eine
freiheitliche demokratie in der schwule
und lesben die volljährig sind wirklich
leben können wie sie wollen
40 jahre dabei und wir haben im
arabischen raum in katar
wo frauenrechte und schwulenrechte
wirklich mit füßen getreten werden und
da in deutschland antreten
da bin ich mal sehr gespannt wie die
diskussion in den nächsten anderthalb
bisher sehe ich überhaupt keine ansätze
die teilnahme deutschlands und anderer
westlicher länder in frage zu stellen
die wärme dort spielen es ist die reden
im übrigen über einen wichtigen sponsor
vom fc bayern münchen auch da würde ich
mir vom vereinbaren eine klare ansage
wünschen habe ich bisher noch nicht
herr schalters dazu würde mich ihre
meinung noch interessieren ja bin ich
bin ich absolut da und da muss ich auch
dem herrn papa vollkommen recht geben
ich bin der meinung diese wm darf nicht
in katar stattfinden leider regiert beim
fußball einfach nur mal das geld an wo
am meisten geld bezahlt wird oder
geschlossen wird da wird haben einfach
die entscheidungen getroffen
wie gesagt katar sollte man auf jeden
fall meiden vor allem der aktuelle
europameister sollte definitiv auch
nicht nach katar fliegen
man kann es gerne boykottieren nur noch
ganz kurz einen kleinen einwand zu der
aussage von memup gerade wo er gesagt
hat volljährige homosexuelle dürfen in
ungarn leben wie immer sie möchten
stimmt so nicht es ist wird ihnen
verwehrt kinder zu adoptieren und somit
können sie nicht leben wie sie wollen
davon abgesehen auch mit 17 weiß ich
schon wo meine sexualität liegt warum
darf ich da noch gar nichts machen diese
zusatz volljährige homosexuelle stört
mich auch und wie gesagt das war noch
mal ganz kurz am rande aber ich finde
herr papa hat recht katar sollte
definitiv nicht stattfinden und wer
hätte gedacht dass am ende zumindest in
einem punkt doch einigkeit unter ihnen
herrscht ich danke ihnen dass sie ihre
unterschiedlichen meinungen dargestellt
haben dann auch wenn sie
unterschiedlicher meinung sind so ist es
doch unerlässlich und wahnsinnig wichtig
dass sie miteinander im dialog stehen
und das miteinander reden
vielen dank herr papke und vielen dank
herr scholtes und ich wünsche ihnen
einen schönen raum
ja und auch euch vielen dank für eure
fragen und eure kommentare jetzt bleibt
die wahnsinnig spannende frage wenn es
draußen nicht ging mit den farben wie
bunt wird es dann drinnen im stadion
ihr wäre zerfahren live im zdf die
vorberichte laufen schon der anpfiff ist
um 9 und ich wünsche einen schönen abend
macht's gut